so I'm currently with my boy Austin cost
super pumped back back home in Sioux
Falls South Dakota Austin is 23 23 23
attorney no 24 next students 24 June so
Austin came off hot on baseball and
business was it what was it on the
business what was the specific uh degree
what was it the Wars of advertising
advertising economics advertising echoes
and then at sdsu and also baseball and
then pitching in baseball
so Austin had a lot of that awesome like
teamwork and hustle with like going to
the weight room and been working out and
learning how to play sport you know
sports are huge for personal development
everything now
so Austin and his brother Chandler and I
go back hell up and for sure so far back
yeah and and so much fun [ __ ] besides
you know hanging out and played sports
and also gaming lots of gaming with so
many cognitive benefits to more more on
the gaming but which is obviously
visible in the cognitive benefits so
Austin is now working at State Farm
which is Insurance Company here they
sell life insurance auto insurance home
insurance and he's trying to break
through as an entrepreneur into some
sort of a field and he's making a big
move out of Sioux Falls and into a
Phoenix in September that's his aim
right now September 2019 and he has a
homeboy his homeboys name's Dilla and
he's going there with Dylan and he and
Dylan so also is now teaching you about
what he and Dylan are strategizing to do
and we're breaking down how Austin's
just got a you know just like I'm doing
right now in San Francisco eat [ __ ]
eat [ __ ] for five years grind be patient
heads down no beer gardens and Netflix
just [ __ ] grinding and hustling and
building the business and building
sustainability so you can hockey
make up in your 30s and 40s and do
whatever you want and help the family
out all good stuff so all right so tell
us about what you and Dylan are looking
to do in Phoenix when you guys get out
there yeah so I mean I'll just kind of
cut up this do it yeah just because
so really you know growing up I don't
really know what I wanted to do and then
they were really all changed I always
tell them this sophomore year spring my
sophomore year my dad he said he'd give
me money to put in the stock market and
that was like just like the switch that
just clicked and then like I started
like reading about investing and then I
started that's really what I was like
okay you know you can't just have a job
like you're not gonna do not get to
where you want to get if you're just
trading your time and so and then oh
that's this is the summer that I came
out to California because me and my
buddy he's been yeah we we both played
baseball and then they had us go out to
San Francisco to play baseball and went
out there we had some nice conversations
all the way and then we start trading
stock yeah I got really big into that
came back start trying to day trade
penny stocks and quickly realized you
know nothing that's not possible I just
didn't put enough time you switched to
real estate investing and just not more
probably than that just how did it get
out of there I see the rat race
everyone says that sir and I just want
to figure out other ways so fast forward
didn't make that happen
coming to college yeah they went after
the job but did make it happen didn't
work hard enough no one to blame on
myself so I started working State that's
right that's a huge point right there
for everyone you just take the blame on
yourself not on other external factors I
tried to play things like on a baseball
it's like no I could have made it happen
that's good so so so we're gonna say
farm it was you know I was the one thing
I will say is I'm appreciative State
Farm because I worked for a really big
you know a good agent he had State Farm
but he does a lot of other things very
good business guy so I ever
but I hit my here mark in August and
then I met Dylan he started working
there in last June and we started I
mentioned business to him and then oh
right away I could just tell because you
know like sometimes you meet somebody
like there's not about it like you can't
have these type of conversations because
it's like you're speaking a different
language - yeah yeah it's like it's
almost like a nine-to-five versus an
entrepreneur literally it's that so so
we start talking we're like okay you
know I went to visit Phoenix in August
and I came back I was kind of not gonna
watch I was kind of depressed I was just
like so then I start talking to Dale and
he was like dude I've been waiting for
somebody to move long story short we've
decided we're gonna move next September
and then those are those little
synchronicities that the universe can
sign it kind of like plug into your life
to kind of give you that push but you
got to be willing to watch what the
universe is trying to give you with
those little presents those little
pushes like Dylan was that little push
and then you're that little push that
pushes Dylan so you cannot let each
other's fires under each others butts
and how you got to go to next step so
yeah keep going yeah and then it shifted
phone we start talking I were on the
golf course so we were talking about
like let's start looking for jobs you
know see what kind of jobs we get and
then I was like dude screw that let's
have a year now let's find a way till
when we get down to Phoenix we don't
have to go get another job because then
we're at square one we're in a better
location but we're still back at square
one oh yeah so we decide this a little
bit different than what you know Allen
does because first of all we always talk
about technically they'd be square to by
the way because square one was where it
would be get a 95 there so if you have
to that's fine and to start up your
entrepreneurial side hustle as you go
anyway you're right yeah you are but I
still is just sounds like okay what's
the most practical way
do this and I've always been into real
estate I got a roundel property well of
investing finance things like that you
know I was like okay that's gonna take
too long to just start acquiring rental
properties finance got quickly realized
that that's that's more like a tenured
other UPS think so all right how do I
get enough money now I start a business
now so that I can get out of this so
that when I'm in Phoenix then I'm
already doing run trying to do it and
just build from there so what I'm doing
it's I don't know if you've heard of it
it's called wholesaling real estate
where basically we find we do a lot of
marketing and find deeply this though
this says deeply discounted homes where
I'll give you an example of somebody
there are three months from free
foreclosure they have $150,000 house
they either go into bankruptcy or they
sell their house so then you can get
really cheap you can get really cheap
real estate or what you do is I don't
want to flip homes I want to it's just
too much work and it was just way too
much work so what I'm what I'm doing is
basically you go to this guy you the
biggest thing is marketing though it's
like fighting these deals so if you find
a deal you go to them and say if someone
is foreclosing on their home they're
unable to pay the mortgage on their
house and then the bank is saying okay
great so now we are going to take the
property because we are the ones that
financed in the first place so they take
the property as does the collateral and
then what you're what the person is
doing is they're moving out of the home
and then the bank now owns the home and
the bank wants to sell the house to
someone at a good price but once the
bank has you can't do this
so you got basically or you got to jump
in before them yes Oh interest in so the
thing is it's it's not just pre
foreclosures just funny motivated so it
could be they inherited the property and
they need cash or they're back on the
taxes tax delinquent or no sales so many
different put it live in Florida and
they have a house in Sioux Falls so
basically what yeah so you're finding
people like I like I'm working on a deal
right now where somebody it's a duplex
and Lennox and
he wants to move to Wisconsin but he has
he needs to get rid of this dad and
until I get sort of the dead
he can't do this other business ventures
general Wisconsin so working on things
so it's just finding motivation and what
am i doing yes so what you're doing is
you you and the seller you sign a
purchase agreement with with those two
guys and then what you can do is then
you have like your investors cash buyers
who have already told me look send me
the deals you have so you send the
purchase agreement say for $70,000
$150,000 Steve sign it for $170,000 and
then you go to your cash buyer send the
deal and say they want to buy from 90
then you sign an assignment of that
purchase agreement assignment of
contract between them for 90 thousand
sent both documents to the title company
the cash buyer they send ninety thousand
dollars to tell a company seventy
thousand goes to the seller twenty
thousand goes to me for finding the deal
so and this is this is kind of a new
thing it's it's a kind of a niche thing
okay
run this run this again one more time
run this whole game example yes so this
deal in Lennox let's go for this deal -
okay so there's a duplex that this guy
wants to move to Wisconsin to start a
business she wants - yeah yeah and he
has a debt and he wants to get rid of
the property so that he can move in and
start a business in Wisconsin yeah okay
and so then how much is this duplex yeah
so on the market for and then how do you
get it at a rate that's even better and
yeah yeah it's really interesting
because first of all you're finding
off-market deals and you know I'm kind
of new so it's key but usually you're
cold calling at a glance you get a list
but basically I we put on now on
Facebook and somebody this guy just
commented wish I quote wish I could
somehow what okay so you might win a
visited them and it's a pretty big
duplex but here's the deal so I'm
talking I want to do a conventional
route of
agent 2 saw his place because then you
know then he has to get ready to start
showing people pay the real estate
commission and really that's the
difference between theater and agent is
that if they want to get rid of it as
soon as possible I can close and you
know a few weeks and what do you mean
you can close yeah so basically you're
matching a buyer with a seller and these
are all cash buyers because the biggest
part of doing the realtor cash buyers
real estate deal is like the financing
takes you know to get a loan mortgage
you know I can take up to a month so
you're sure but also that's a difference
yeah but do you need a license of sorts
in order no no my parents thought it was
illegal that's nice
Oh interesting so you just basically
match a cash buyer with itself and then
you just get a commission yeah yeah and
then why would that be illegal these
people because but I will say 95% of all
transactions are gonna be through a
realtor 5% of people don't want to deal
with the realtor so your basic we're
basically trying to find receptive
because he doesn't want to get us house
all like prepared and ready for having a
real having people come in to read and
visit it or is your rate less than a
realtor yeah literally tell them like
hey if you want top dollar go go to a
realtor
I'm not we're not going to be top dollar
but what we can provide you is you don't
have to pay closing costs
you can close within a month we can take
it all this [ __ ] that you have in your
house you know to deal with it and like
I said oh interesting they don't have to
lug this [ __ ] they don't have to pay
closing costs they can you can get it
other than bonds situations so basically
just and you'll give them a cash buyer
yeah so realtor doesn't necessarily get
it did they do get a cash back because
even if they get a mortgage or thank you
know they won't be okay yeah it's
something just cash buyer it's like if
somebody has very easy access to a
credit montre or they can use it's just
got it quick five minutes then quick
financing but something like this this
deal it's interesting because talk to
multiple Realtors like
don't you think it's or they all said
like 120 125 110 worst but the problem
is that the only thing that might need a
new roof but that's kind of irrelevant
basically if this is the situation
because what we're doing is we're just
we're problem solvers if something needs
to get out of their house when we come
in to help them out of their house and
so this guy it's fifty five thousand
dollars leftovers mortgage but he has
twenty five thousand dollars on on a
credit card from put in put into the
house so he does the only way I can go
to Wisconsin and move on from this place
is if I can get all that debt cleared
they said if you can give me eighty
thousand eighty k okay I'm still trying
to figure out if I want to do that
because then what I probably do is signs
for eighty and then pitch it to my cash
buyers for two hundred because they I
mean I mean I've talked to like three or
four Realtors all say 125 in like like a
house half the size a block down just
looks like 120 yeah yeah so that would
be the internet first I'm working on the
other one too but basically if you can
get him eighty you can take twenty plus
there's all that you'll have to move
this [ __ ] out and all this other kind of
stuff and so maybe you let's say ten or
something away yeah and see the cash
part does all that so all I'll do is if
somebody agrees do honored I just send
the two contracts to the title company I
don't even have to go to the closing and
then they just send me the check for my
finder's fee
gotcha if so big - where's all that
ships these though who's the middleman
that they need to send the title to that
goes into escrow the title and the money
and just transfer and get the feed who
does that Oh work it's like I'm the
middleman but I sent it to a title
company that does all of that and that's
a little poison Getty abstract I know
getting abstract tell it's interesting
though because I called all there's like
five in Sioux Falls and like before if
I'm didn't even know at this whatever
like yeah that's a legal a lawyer said
this is illegal inside there I was like
the one company so they can do in that
but they still have to talk to the
president of the title company because
he deals with
the complex closes so we look at our
long conversation and he's like yeah you
can do this like but if you get these
two contracts make sure when you bring
into our office make sure tell the
secretary like to give them to me so I
can make sure to make sure everything's
kosher yeah yeah yeah that's cool okay
but then this is so this is a generous
this is 5% of all real estate deals are
going through something like this whole
selling real estate don't give me a good
example basically so apple apples at
$150 a share right now if you could buy
it right now for $70 share you would
obviously do that cuz I think it's very
soft very what it's worth so basically
you're just getting properties that big
discount and it's not like I don't want
to do this for my managing capital and
then like more think progressive things
like what you you do a lot but I'm just
trying to be practical so that I can get
out of this job yeah and not be
completely financially stressed yeah
that's that's the bottom line and then
you want to do a couple of these
wholesale real estate projects in Sioux
Falls metro area it sounds right and
keep doing that in Phoenix for a bit and
hopefully you can launch yourself off
with enough cash to where you can focus
on that full-time in Phoenix for yeah
for a couple of years and and you can
delegate this pretty easily to you just
have for people that are looking for the
deals and yeah you can have like cold
you can hire a cold caller somebody so
it's very easy to automate it and that'd
be the hoffman thing you keep the
business but then I don't want to be
putting in 60 hours a week to eventually
it gets to a because you know you'll
launch yourself off with finding the
wholesale real estate deals that you
want and when you get to Phoenix and
then you'll also be able to pour portion
chunk of your time for your next
endeavoring and that way you'll get to
go from want from square 2 to 3 2
and keep going in the direction you
wanna go okay now so besides how like
besides that deal that you have that
you're looking at analytics you're
basically find in like five ten fifteen
of these because you got a you know you
got a go law of averages you gotta go a
hundred of these numbers yeah keep going
keep going you have to find like you
know one of these a day you'll find a
database yeah yeah it's gets to that
point yeah I got another one I got two
from Facebook yeah that's where it is
you just you do a lot of marketing it's
you know Facebook marketing
pay-per-click on Google I have a website
where I'm trying to get it to where when
you search sell your house for like sell
my house fast sue fall there's summer
house and I'm on the first page that you
click on it and then they put in their
information the website and I get an
email
I gotta leave but the biggest thing is
you can pull like you like I have a
software word I can pull all houses that
are more than two years tax delinquent
and owners don't live at the address but
I work so I can't call those people some
try to find somebody they can just call
for me which I have up you can make the
calls on lunch which that's Amedeo we're
gonna live together like that's totally
it's fairly big time cause II should
that yeah so I do agree yeah that's
hustle I know that's I'm trying to be
about your day off work call yeah your
whole day off work 9 to 6 call all 100
leads that have stacked up you know take
a day off work just to work on your
other project yeah but really I mean we
all it comes out of the same thing what
he's gonna find something that you can
do to where terms and everyone says that
but like it's I've realized how true it
is because yeah I've been working a
full-time job for a year and a half and
it just it just eats a man and I
complain all the time and I don't know I
should be complaining it's like more
this is what it is get out of it get out
of some people it's good you know you
got your firing yourself to to find
something else that's good that you're
gonna bet you're feeling this raw spirit
moving you towards something else so
what else should you know this is good
with some wholesale real estate you know
convo you and you know that were you are
pursuing here maybe it would be
interesting to mention what you're using
you know you said you have software that
you're using find tax delinquent
properties and so what else are you
doing to to automate the embalm leads
you're trying to show up high on this
your rankings oh well to automate it you
mean yeah because you got to increase
your efficiency right now yeah see you
know I actually I think that's that's a
step that we're not even at yet I think
we need to be getting the deals like
we're putting the man-hours we're
calling people getting the deals and
then one servers deal if I get one deal
like one deal will change your life cuz
I need been your validation your
validate it's gonna pay it's gonna work
yeah so like but that first one in yeah
and then but the thing is once you want
to start getting designers five deals a
month then basically what you need is
you need to hire a cold color hire
somebody to pull the lists for you and
they need to have a good website to
where you can get leads from just people
people searching on Google those are the
best leads cuz they're literally because
they need it so but you are not putting
all of your eggs in the Lennox duplex
basket so you're diversifying your eggs
putting them in the other host of really
state options so you gotta find those
other wholesome listed options that
learn really you got to really go hard
on that in the next month you have to
start off the year go really hard wanna
get that validation yeah yeah yeah it's
more being official in your time though
because I mean we always say like be
medellín like
like there's none I got to work with
Jason Josh but mostly made for now we
were to say like God would just do this
all day
so yeah blow or not doing we can't do it
all day so I would say winners are just
who enters it just in the circumstances
but I mean yeah that's it's it just
putting in it's a it's a pretty
straightforward business plan but it's
not easy
make it straightforward what you need to
do to get the list column going
appointments close videos yeah it's
simple not easy but like I said like
next month is all about getting the one
to break through you know getting the
one to close getting the validation
month and that's good that you got
someone well say is that cuz me and you
we have great conversations just about
like like things like more progressive
things and I want to get into some of
that stuff too but we always argue about
sweet powers I like up about like like
and I was always the guy was like I need
to get funny I need some sort so he's
pulling awesome out yeah
live in like an SRO you know the most
janky-ass place just so that he could
have launched off to start connecting to
the different powerful high-level people
out there and that would slowly inching
forward into what you want to do or not
but also it went to bed I don't think as
ideal open environment for like
wholesale real estate yeah but you can
do this anywhere but obviously I always
think way to big picture which honestly
is kind of a bad thing sometimes they
said like folks you want to do now like
they have event
what so there so there's a good way to
view it it's not it's though what needs
to happen in the short term while you
have this massive vision and then you're
basically meeting these two as you build
and then you have long-term patients
short term yeah the one thing we talked
about was meeting those two as well but
technologies excuse us
well if you have discipline just yeah
like we always talk about this
no no notifications volume always off
all the apps are no notifications across
all the devices laptop cell phone all
the devices so that way you're using
your devices as a one-way communication
method outbound when you need and you're
not getting Bing Bing being pulled into
notifications highly recommend that for
you and for that yeah
and for people view and turn off the
notifications as soon as possible all of
them off isn't it crazy I like you can
just give your good but it's probably
better at the change I'm there it's a
great New Year's resolution is to turn
off your notifications for off 2019 it
will save anything else that we should
mention I don't know I would say that's
a four years I mean I think most people
who didn't watch you already had this
mindset but I just you gotta get in the
right but instead of just not trading
your time and if it's the if there's a
book out I'll recommend I say this read
Rich Dad Poor Dad
oh yeah we're chef poor dad's late yeah
do you it's my cousin cuz I was like oh
I wasn't feeling
his mindset so yeah we're gonna need to
try to change that but yeah
well I would say yeah if you want to if
you want to go also blessed yeah yeah I
would say figure out how you want your
life to to be look like it then figure
out how to make that happen
that's right cuz I figured out what I
want to look like yeah and you got to
see it to be it and like you said you
have that really high level vision of
what you want to become and you got
these short-term action items the steps
that you gotta take to keep getting to
the next and those two things meet and
again efficiency with time effectiveness
with time we're sitting in front of
Austin's and Dennis the house lane right
now 50 different hats open and I'm sure
on your phone you have all your
notifications on across your apps and
you know Twitter notification also and
you're browsing through Twitter
oestrogen you we're in the middle of
working and so actually logging all of
your leads into a customer relationship
management platform and having that
shared with dylon and having you guys
find thirty of those in January so that
way you can close one by the end of the
month that's the way to hustle it
through and it's harder with the nine to
five especially when you also have to
give all of your calls during that
window that makes it hard but you can do
the lead finding from 6 p.m. until 11
p.m. and then you can call them at from
like potentially even like 7:30 or 8
a.m. until maybe 8:30 or something do
some calls then and then do some calls
at lunch and then potentially try and
get you know a couple calls in right at
the end if your shift potentially do
your best you know take the day off as
your best as you can and yeah there's
yeah yeah so that's um that's it calling
calling the weekends possible you know
once you're in once you're out of that
job then it's like they're near you then
it's all you it's like what are you
gonna do yeah you're swimmin on your own
well and then the next thing is when
you're
on your own yet so many people like you
pulled into Netflix and beer gardens and
chillin they get pulled again so you
know even though most people do the
Netflix beer gardens from 6 p.m. to 11
p.m. every day after their 95 even when
you get to your little next lily pad of
your entrepreneurship you will still get
pulled into distractive mindsets as do I
totally not always growing always
learning and I swear it still happens to
me all the time and I'm always you mean
to catch myself as fast as possible and
move on to actually executing as quickly
as possible get that [ __ ] done in
January there any of those suckers close
one yeah that's good stuff yeah good
stuff this is a new always having
conversations yeah I'm really looking
forward to Austin launching off from
from the this I was talking to your wall
upstairs for a bit and surprised he
hasn't left yet hey he's the one he's
your easier one that's gonna fly out
there and I will check back up on Austin
soon we will update so much much love
everyone let us let us you know some of
your thoughts we'd love to hear from you
in the comments below on what you're
building into the world and how you're
executing your dreams and don't forget
manifest that destiny sacrifice at all
hustle grind head down going build it so
you can hockey stick up and be free as a
bird in the future much love